Starting in 2003, American Chopper dominated
reality television for ten years, giving a
look at the inside workings of Orange County
Choppers with a mix of competition and drama
that provided a model for all reality shows
that have followed.
Unlike most so-called reality shows, though,
the fighting, cursing, crying, welding, and
painting on American Chopper was real.
Here's a look at the untold truth of American
Chopper.
Drinking and welding
In his book The Ride of a Lifetime, Paul Teutul,
Sr. discusses his 15-year drug and alcohol
addiction, which ended when he went to rehab
on the advice of his wife in 1985.
He wrote,
"Somehow, she talked me into going into rehab,
something I thought I'd never do.
But I wanted to have one last good drunk.
So the day before I was set to go into rehab,
I got totally plastered.
I drank a half-gallon of wine, a pint of brandy,
and I took six Valiums."
While Paul Sr. was ultimately able to stop
his drinking, his sons Mikey and Paul Jr.
both had issues with drugs and alcohol, with
Paul Jr. going to rehab at age 16.
Father-son feud
Fights between the Pauls were a regular occurrence
on the show, driving much of the onscreen
drama.
But the most heated argument ever captured
on camera happened in 2009, when a chair-throwing
Paul Junior was dressed down by his father
for sleeping on the job and showing up late.
It seemed like the perfect reality TV show
plotline — but this wasn't scripted drama.
Paul Senior actually fired his son, which
opened a whole new can of worms, because the
show's contract stipulated that Paul Junior
had to be involved.
The network, TLC, filed a notice of default,
forcing Paul Senior to bring Paul Junior back
as a contractor so he could stay on the show
without technically working for his dad.
But then things got even uglier.
The new contract had a clause that allowed
Paul Senior to buy out his son's stake in
Orange County Choppers.
Junior refused, and dad sued him for a million
dollars.
Junior took him to court and won, retaining
his stake in the company, but the two eventually
decided it would be better for their relationship
if they just stopped working together entirely.
A tragic accident
In 2010, Paul Junior branched out and opened
his own custom motorcycle shop, Paul Junior
Designs.
But the business began under a dark cloud.
Shortly after opening, a man contracted by
the building's owner to repair the roof fell
and died.
In a statement, Paul Junior said,
"This was a tragic accident and, although
I've never met this man, my deepest condolences
and prayers go out to his family and friends."
Wedding snub
In 2010, Paul Junior married Rachael Biester,
a model he'd met on an episode of American
Chopper.
In advance of their wedding, the couple appeared
on TLC's show Say Yes to the Dress, and even
met with a chef from TLC's Cake Boss to really
hammer home the fact that TLC pretty much
owns these people.
One person, however, did not attend Paul and
Rachael's wedding: Paul Senior, who skipped
the event even though he was invited.
Ouch.
Case of stolen idea
In 2014, a Florida man named Christ Tavantzis
sued the two Pauls and Orange County Choppers
for copyright infringement.
Tavantzis, who suffered from polio and was
wheelchair-bound until his death in February
2016, claimed that he pitched the idea of
a handicap-accessible, three-wheel motorcycle
to members of the shop at a bike show in 2008.
Tavantzis contended that this bike, which
the American Chopper team built at the beginning
of 2010 in conjunction with the Christopher
& Dana Reeve Foundation, was a ripoff of his
original idea, for which Tavantzis held a
patent.
"I honestly mean from the bottom of my heart
that we're are honored to do this bike.
It's all about giving back, so we're doing
this."
As of the making of this video, the case is
still making its way through the court system.
Sidekicks gone wild
While his father and brother were settling
their differences onscreen and in court, younger
son Mikey shifted his energies from Orange
County Choppers to other schemes.
In November 2010, he opened Wolf Gang Gallery,
an art gallery that showcased, among other
works, his own paintings.
A year after he opened the gallery, Mikey
launched a line of gourmet pasta sauces under
the company name FarQueue Products, which
carried flavors like Porcine Orgy Sausage
Supreme.
One of the show's other loveable sidekicks
didn't have such a pleasant end to his time
with Orange County Choppers.
Shop-hand Cody Connelly was a regular in the
show's early days, and at one point was given
a chopper for all his hard work, which he
helped design.
However, Cody later filed a lawsuit for $250,000
in damages, claiming he never received the
chopper, and that Orange County Choppers continued
to use his likeness on promotional materials
after he'd left the company.
He eventually settled out of court and returned
to the show — but working for Paul Junior
instead.
Rumors and lies
In recent years, Orange County Choppers has
been dogged by persistent rumors that the
company is in dire financial straits and headed
for foreclosure.
When word got out that their headquarters
was being sold, Paul Senior had to go on the
radio to assure fans that they were doing
fine.
Around the same time as the foreclosure rumors
started swirling, strange reports surfaced
suggesting Paul Senior had died in a motorcycle
accident.
According to Snopes.com, on April 18, 2016,
the website Iron Demons doctored a real article
about another man's death in a motorcycle
crash in Louisiana to make it look like it
was Paul Sr.'s death.
The rumors went viral, prompting Orange County
Choppers to post a rebuttal on Facebook.
The show may be dead for now, but its stars,
at least, are still alive and kicking.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!